[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia cuba está insatisfecha las
recientes protestas raras veces vistas
en la isla evidenciaron la frustración
de una parte considerable de la
población que alegaba libertad y el fin
de la dictadura
[Aplausos]
si bien dicho malestar tiene asidero en
la crítica situación sanitaria por la
pandemia de coronavirus así como el
desabastecimiento de alimentos y
medicinas la raíz del malestar viene de
mucho tiempo atrás cuba es actualmente
el único país comunista de américa
latina' su famosa revolución de 1959
despistó a muchos en el continente pues
poco se sospechaba que la isla vid haría
hacia el socialismo un sistema de
gobierno que le costó un bloqueo
económico de quien fuera su mayor socio
comercial eeuu uno de los principales
actores regionales que para finales de
la década de 1950 no sospechó que la
revolución de castro fuera comunista fue
la prensa de eeuu de hecho el periódico
de new york times calificó a fidel
castro- de robin hood y lo mostró a él
ya sus hombres como una suerte de héroes
guerrilleros encargados de tumbar el
régimen opresor del dictador fulgencio
batista el avance por las montañas
cubanas de fidel castro y varios de sus
hombres como su hermano raúl camilo
cienfuegos huber matos y el médico
argentino ernesto ché guevara
las páginas de los periódicos
estadounidenses la presión sobre el
dictador batista quien había perdido el
apoyo de washington lo forzó a huir de
la isla con 300 millones de dólares en
la mañana del primero de enero de 1959
dejándole las puertas abiertas a la
revolución de los barbudos en principio
washington dio el visto bueno y legítimo
el nuevo gobierno de castro pero las
cosas cambiaron con las reformas que
trajo consigo la revolución para
favorecer a los campesinos y a los más
pobres de cuba- castro ejecutó una
reforma agraria a costa de expropiar las
industrias y las propiedades de los
estadounidenses en la isla un hecho que
detonó la enemistad con washington el
presidente dwight eisenhower asesorado
por su vice presidente richard nixon
aprobó un plan secreto para derrocar a
castro por medio de una intervención
militar el peligro de que cuba se
convirtiera en un satélite soviético en
plena guerra fría era la mayor
justificación pero el plan que había
diseñado a nixon se congeló cuando en
1960 perdió las elecciones presidencial
contra el joven candidato john
fitzgerald kennedy
kennedy se opuso a ejecutar dicha
intervención pero finalmente accedió
cuando el periodista tatsu del 'new york
times' descubrió el plan de la invasión
y lo publicó pese al intento de kennedy
de que no se imprimiera la invasión a
bahía cochinos un despliegue aéreo y el
desembarco de más de 1300 cubanos
exiliados para derrocar a fidel castro
fue un fracaso el comandante fidel
movilizó sus tropas y extinguió con
éxito el avance contra revolucionario y
dicho intento por derrocarlo hizo que
castró buscará aliarse imperiosamente
con la unión soviética liderada por
nikita khrushchev castró insistía en un
acuerdo militar con la unión soviética
que incluyera la instalación en la isla
de misiles balísticos de mediano alcance
r12 que apuntarán hacia eeuu tras varios
días y aflojes khrushchev accedió a
enviar los misiles a cuba- entre junio y
octubre de 1962 de manera secreta para
equiparar la amenaza estadounidense de
sus misiles júpiter que apuntaban desde
turquía hacia el suelo soviético
además enviaron 43 mil soldados
soviéticos a la isla pero la
inteligencia de eeuu pronto descubrió
las cabezas nucleares en cuba por medio
de la violación del espacio aéreo con
sus aviones espías u2 octubre de 1962
fue un mes de altísima tensión el mundo
estaba en vilo por el estallido de una
posible guerra nuclear entre eeuu y la
unión soviética luego de que kennedy
ordenara un bloqueo naval y aéreo sobre
cuba afortunadamente las negociaciones
entre kruschev y kennedy surtieron
efecto y las bases soviéticas de misiles
nucleares en cuba fueron desmanteladas
fidel castró había quedado frustrado
indignado tachó a los soviéticos de
cobarde especial que el acuerdo entre
moscú y washington le favorecía ya que a
eeuu se le había pedido que desechará
los planes de derrocarlo ahora eeuu
llevaría la disputa al plano de la
diplomacia y el comercio durante esos
primeros años de la década de 1960
washington impuso un embargo económico
comercial y financiero sobre cuba que
incluyó alimentos y medicinas
cuba quedó aislada desabastecida y solo
pudo hacer frente al bloqueo gracias al
apoyo incondicional de la unión
soviética pero con la caída del muro de
berlín en 1989 y la disolución de la
unión soviética en 1991 cuba quedó
desamparada esos años sin el sustento
soviético se conocieron en la isla como
el período especial a la isla no
llegaban alimentos y medicinas había
constantes cortes de luz la economía se
desangraba y los cubanos enquistaron un
hartazgo que pronto estalló en las
protestas de agosto de 1994 conocidas
como el maleconazo la isla no vivía unas
manifestaciones tan masivas desde el
triunfo de la revolución de 1959 fidel
castro- tuvo que abrir rápidamente las
fronteras y permitir una apertura
económica para apaciguar la protesta el
maleconazo de 1994 derivó en la crisis
de los balseros de 1995 cubanos
desesperados que se aventuraron a cruzar
por mar 144 kilómetros para llegar a las
costas estado
si bien la situación de cv era mucho más
precaria en la década de 1990 la actual
crisis de los cubanos tiene mayor eco
internacional por el alcance de las
redes sociales a pesar de los cortes de
internet ejecutados por el gobierno de
miguel díaz canel un gobierno que
intenta emular lo hecho por fidel
castro- de llamar a sus seguidores para
enfrentar a los contra revolucionarios
así concluimos hoy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]
ah